you never know what to expect from
watching season 8 of Dance Moms people
leave enjoying the show nearly every
single episode and it's a whole lot of
fun
well hopefully our nose doesn't bleed
because I'm dr. Staci we'll put you in
timeout watch until the end to see Abby
parents in major shade brick Islands way
you won't believe how ruthless she is
here are some of the most outrageous
deleted scenes season 8 has stopped stop
Lily your self in you know what you're
doing
eating cake off the floor Abby Lee
Miller made it clear that she didn't
think Giannina had it in her to be Brady
but in season 8 episode 5d anine did
just that the set Tricia and Brady extra
hard after all it was Brady's last week
on the show in this extended scene we
see just how bitter Tricia really felt
these ladies got their cake and they're
gonna eat it too
and then and one of the funniest
extended scenes of all time the girls
start eating the cake from off the floor
Sara's rehearsal it's rare to see
footage of the dancers rehearsing their
entire solos for more than a few seconds
in this behind-the-scenes clip we get to
see Sarah rehearsing America's
Sweethearts and we also see a softer
side to Abby now devil pay let's go way
back here but see a bad leg does hurt
bad leg that's what's weird we're so
used to seeing her yell that it comes to
the surprise to see here teaching her
students in a calm and soothing voice
[Music]
good shame on you if you thought it was
strange to see miss Abby teaching her
students in a low-key manner don't worry
she's back to her old self in this
pyramid day extended scene Abby places
Lily at the bottom of the pyramid and
goes on to say that Lily has messed up
on a dance every single week then she
looks Lily straight in the eyes and says
I expect more from you
shame on you despite feeling like she
let her teacher down Lily takes the
criticism and powers through like the
back of my hand and it's extended scene
we see a be grilling Lily once again but
this time she's not ready to take the
criticism and it's probably because her
mother is whispering in her ear while
rehearsing the group dance of widows
Abbey Singles Lily out and kicks
everyone else out of the room but later
on Lily complains to the camera saying
she knows the dance like the back of her
hand trust fall Abby might come off as a
super strict teacher and well she is but
that's not to say that she can't have a
little fun in this extended scene we see
Abby teaching your students that group
dance the healer and things get funny
real fast
savanah throws herself backwards
expecting Brady to catch her but he
misses his mark and she falls instead of
scolding Brady for letting his partner
down Abby laughs it was really funny it
was let's do this
trust exercises nobody was the moms are
quick to point out that she would have
scolded anyone else except for Brady not
everything is about you in this deleted
scene we see Stacey complaining about
Presley's solo she's under the
impression that Abby stole her idea for
Presley's solo the other moms are quick
to point out that not everything is
about Stacie and Lilly not every
situation and everything has to come
back to being about hurting you or
hurting Lilly and we have to admit
Stacie does often think that the world
revolves around her and her daughter oh
wait it is about you she's just like
down there thinking like how many ways
can I swap Lilly and Stacy things oops
we might have spoken too soon turns out
Stacy was right all along
Abby did steal her idea for Presley's
solo Abby confirms with Stacy's
suspected during her one-on-one time
with the camera she explains that she
originally had Lilly doing this solo but
after hearing Stacy complain about her
choreography Abby decided to give to
possess solo to Presley nice when Stacy
don't you know who you're messing with
sabotage in this clip we find out that
Joanne thinks stacy is sabotaging
Giannina gia name confesses that she's a
little nervous
according to jo-ann theanine had a
nosebleed and Stacy made her seek
medical attention which resulted in her
having to miss school that's when Joanne
times insane well hopefully her nose
doesn't bleed because I'm dr. Stacy I'll
put you in timeout Stacy's obviously
surprised by the comments but Joanne
takes things a step further by accusing
Stacy of sabotage in the end Joanne
tells Stacy to keep her daughter's name
out of her mouth this fight went from
zero to a hundred real quick but we're
still not sure what the moms for
complaining about Abby's encouraging
words Abby Lee Miller gets a bad rep but
she's not always the bad guy and this
scene IV takes Lily out for some treats
and gives her a few encouraging words
Abby tells Lily that she needs to be the
lily she knows and loves happy makes it
clear that Lily needs to block out all
the drama and focus on dancing they hug
it out and share a super-sweet moment
and when the waiter asks Abby if she
needs anything else
anything else I get free right husband
that's it
enjoy break a leg kiddo it's like Abby
loves during shave looks way which is
why she totally referenced Brooks
accident while casting the roles for the
healer Abby tells Savannah that she has
to pretend like her leg is busted
she gives Savannah examples of what
could have happened she says maybe you
were hit by a car crushed by a school
bus this was a total Javid Brooke whose
father ran over her foot with his car
which one of these deleted scenes made
you laugh the most tell us in the
comments thanks for watching the things
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe so you never
miss a video we'll catch you next time
[Music]